Olha só, você já ouviu que carne
vermelha pode matar? Pois é, um novo
estudo com 16.000 pessoas acabou de
virar essa mesa. Veja bem o que eles
descobriram. Pesquisadores canadenses da
Universidade McMaster acompanharam essas
pessoas por mais de uma década e pasm
não só a carne não aumentou o risco de
morte, como quem comia mais proteína
animal teve até uma pequena redução na
mortalidade por câncer. Isso mesmo que
você ouviu. Agora veja bem, o grande
problema dos estudos anteriores que
condena a carne é que eles misturavam
tudo o mesmo saco. Nugget, salsicha,
presunto. Isso não é carne, é produto
ultra processado, cheio de química. A
carne em Natura, aquele bife que você
compra no açogue, é completamente
diferente. É proteína de verdade,
combinoácos essenciais que o seu corpo
precisa. O problema nunca foi a carne em
si, mas sim o que a indústria faz com
ela. Então, na próxima refeição, pode
comer o seu bife sem culpa. Só escolha
cortes de qualidade. Prepare na grelha o
assado e combin com vegetais.